[Musique]
et petit un peu jeune pour faire des
cocktails un peu vieux pour sortir si
tard
pourquoi la carte et pas autre chose
c'est le plus grand trésor qui est
toujours pas été retrouvé 5 milliards
facile mais c'est une légende je suis
pas de cet avis
[Musique]
il ya 500 ans
ma famille a découvert un immense trésor
avant d'être treille
beaucoup de gens n'ont cherché tout 120
vous tournez les clés de gauche à droite
en même temps
merci vous avez failli me tuer tu avais
dit dans son sac c'est une chance sur 2
j'ai pris au hasard d'accord seulement
l'or n'était pas le seul but du voyage
il y avait quelque chose de plus
précieux
cette croix une histoire des plus
tragiques imprimés de sang
ça va
ne fait pas chaud clés
tu m'as laissé tomber en route fallait
quelqu'un s'occupe de la croix
non
d'après ton frère il manquait une pièce
au puzzle
tu connais mon faire simple tu imagines
pas avec qui tu es associés
qu'est ce que tu me cache d'autres
au vainqueur pékin
comment ils vont les sortir de là
[Musique]
et baissez vos armes mais d'autres
bizarre soul men of la puberté est
proche petit on a réuni toi aussi un
jour